it's the European Union's biggest
economic and financial project since the
Euro single currency the banking Union
and ambitious new safety mechanism to
ensure that EU member states will be
able to weather the financial crises of
the future not only that the system's
likely to help increase the flow of
credit and boost economic growth as
confidence grows that Europe's banks are
all using the same rule book had we had
five years back what we are working on
now we still would have had a crisis but
we would not have had the crisis that we
had it would have been considerably more
easily contained the economic effects
would have been smaller there by the
negative effects on growth and
unemployment would have been less in a
nutshell the banking union's meant to
prevent the disorderly collapse of any
financial or credit institution and the
chaotic economic fallout this might
produce it's made up of three components
the first is a supervisor to watch over
the euro zone's 130 biggest banks and
thousands of smaller ones around the EU
if they need help from November 2014
this role the so-called single
supervision mechanism would fall to the
European Central Bank it would be
responsible for licensing credit
institutions ensuring that Bank
regulations are respected and have the
power to shut banks down if necessary
the second component is a single
resolution mechanism this would see the
creation of an authority backed by a
fund which would decide how to wind down
or restructure banks that are no longer
viable the European Commission could
play a role here in tandem with EE use
finance ministers thirdly EU member
states would eventually have a network
of national systems for protecting
people's savings to discourage massive
withdrawals from a bank when things
turned sour in the case of a bank
failure up to 100,000 euros per
depositor per bank would be protected
someone in de masta telenovela pasco
revolutionary poori bonk does it razon
you okay look girl yo-yo ma
unique Yoko info ah stability des una
horita por tanto to train you open
portal magellanic event we pay our own
is also the system aunt agree pascal
federal the supervision ido reservation
donkus poco de between do-si-do redic no
economic uma política mo sujey new voice
and siblings occupier accepted avec de
boku the description however time is of
the essence the single resolution
mechanism must be endorsed by the
european parliament and the assembly
sits for the last full plenary of its
term in mid-april just before the next
EU elections 2014 is a challenging year
we have the election for the European
Parliament we have a new commission
coming in and if we want to have these
rules in place at the end of next year
the first go in the council needs to be
finalised in these days then we can
start the so-called trilogue with the
European Parliament and hopefully come
to a final conclusion in the council in
the course of 2014 but then obviously
you need to give member states some time
for national implementation so the hurry
may look hurried to the outside but in
reality we still have still quite some
work ahead of us if all the deadlines
are met the single resolution authority
and its fund could become operational in
early 2015 but for that to happen the
final details need to be ironed out by
finance ministers first hopefully by the
end of this month